yes the world's funniest all right no
one is funnier with tech no yes okay cuz
no don't mess that up an article all
right you know all right all right so
you just moved here from Chicago yeah
how's the how are you adjusting to
Hollywood life it's crazy yeah you know
from a big city already so it wasn't
coming here wasn't a huge deal in terms
of well actually the traffic is worse
here traffic is like Satan here yeah
it's it's different worse but know that
the life is good they're a lot more
youtubers here so I get to do a lot more
things you know Chicago was lonely and
crying and curled up in a ball about
myself and I couldn't do anything but
now I get to pretend like I have a life
it's great and you're still shooting
your apartment yes yes in my apartment
knows no fancy studios so what makes it
what makes a shooting in your apartment
so special as a person I'm just having
you know being in a studio with all the
yeah all the wonderful equipment yeah I
think it just makes it a lot more
personal people I don't think people on
YouTube the audience wants to show they
want you know just to see how some dual
is and what he thinks about you know and
in his own personal life so that's what
I try to bring out you know that's why I
shoot at an angle where they see my
couch and my brand-new chair and and I
didn't you know everything so they they
kind of just say hey this is his home
he's talking about tech and
entertainment in his phone and since you
came here you've also gotten some roles
as a co-host for sure
what's trending oh yeah and Leo Laporte
Network yeah how do you how do you
manage to you know have all these uh
have all these gigs well you know still
doing here
getting Europe I don't sleep that's it
there's no sleep involved so what the
co-hosting thing yeah she she'll call me
up and say hey can you cut us this week
or can you co-host this day and I try to
be as open and as available as possible
I love what's trending and this week in
tech and and those twit networks I just
I've kind of met Leo through other
channels and you know he loves having me
on so whatever I have some breaking
YouTube news I'll message him I say hey
I'll be a good guy to be on the show so
I'll push myself on him to be on the
show when I can nice going back to your
YouTube channel why is it why is
technology fascinated you so much to the
point that you're making making these
videos for like audience going back for
years when I got my first job in check
working at a Best Buy when they first
opened Best Buy was just showing my age
slightly uh I started working with them
in 94 when they opened up a brand new
and I was just fascinating you know the
store was huge tech computers were just
brand new and I always wanted to be part
of stuff that's new so since then and I
ran my own computer business I ran my
own consulting business and I did
technology for a school system I've
always been a part of tech and mostly
consumer tech my helping people showed
them how to use things so it it's kind
of translated really well over to
YouTube where I'm essentially doing the
same thing I'm doing I'm helping them
understand it in a way that is humorous
but that they understand it an easier
way did you find your like sense of
humor while you were you know that can
your days at best fire yeah I had it
there but I was I was still a little
little timid there but what really kind
of opened me up was working in a school
well we know you have 30 40 kids in
front of you you you have to you have to
be funny I mean I think my jokes are
awful but they laughed
yeah I I worked at elementary Scott
taught every brave from Katie I left
there because I was kind of
kind of irritated with how the school
system started turning to more political
versus just helping kids and a lot of
the kids weren't getting technology
especially in hammer city they weren't
getting technology training properly
because the teachers we're scared to use
it so if they don't want to use it then
the kids wouldn't know about it so these
inner-city kids are always behind so I
started my own company basically to try
to reach as many schools as possible
look teaching teachers you know and I
use humor with them I try to relax them
saying this is not a big deal this and
they they love their workshops and I
didn't so I kind of I kind of tested my
humor so to speak with the kids and then
with the adults and then it's kind of
merged to you to you you Bennett even a
teacher for like a few years yeah
inspired you to be inspired to get into
the educational field it was kind of
accidental it was a funny story behind
that because my growing up I always told
my mom I was on the challenge I always
told her I hated kids because I did I
literally like little kids who could not
stand them just running around and
snot-nosed and everything this could not
stand yes and I said I'm never having
them I don't like no kid kids and then
all of a sudden I end up working at a
school she calls me she's like did you I
was like leave me alone
there was no snacks I was working at our
apartment I would have may have lived an
apartment complex in Seattle and they
had a cabana area were you know I was
young so if I 1890 I used to go there
and just like she hoots or whatever and
I guess you know then I was interacting
with the other teenagers of kids there
and one day the director came out and
she said you know you're really good
with the kids you know why don't you
work here at the center the apartment
center and then will deduct off your
rent and I was like I'll do it for the
rent I'll do it for the rent deduction
because that's not whatever I don't care
about and yeah I just I just kind of
fell in love with with this aspect of
helping people and I've always been a
customer service and this to me this was
another form of customer service it was
you know helping some kids in yeah and
then I end up yeah I decided to you know
kind of change my direction in water
after that and it's been great like I
really loved it again I will still be
doing it in my head and just been for
you know losing my interest because of
the adults the kids are never been a
problem it's always been the kids don't
know the Delta of 80s you ever feel that
your your videos are like educating
people yeah matter of fact that was my
one of my main goes when i when i after
i started when i open up that school
tech TV it was really okay i have this
education background how can i teach
without making people know that i'm
teaching because it they've realized on
now they realize we don't have you they
realize they're being you know they've
been taught it you know they'll resist
it people just don't even eat you don't
wanna be taunted so I've said it that's
why I can incorporate the humor try to
make it funny and where they just they
just don't realize that hey I just
learned something today so that's always
been my my thing almost every video I
try to keep some lesson or some
principle or something I want them to
get something out the video or I failed
right so let's say let's imagine you go
back to you teaching people it's a this
time it's you're teaching a class about
you know being on YouTube what would be
on your what would be on your lesson
plan oh wow I wasn't expecting that
question that um how do you do that to
me I think the first thing is not so
much how to get popular on YouTube as
how to deal with failure on YouTube I
think you need to get to the inner
person first you never you know find out
why are you doing it what's your purpose
what are you expecting out of it and how
to deal with bad people who are gonna
stare you down for putting out your
content nothing okay that's one of my
mistakes
I I didn't know how bad people can be
that one ain't here oh this is gonna be
fun and like oh my god you're talking
about me you know like what why did he
tear me down I'm just trying to be nice
and teach something and yeah it it's
it's bad I'm still I'm still even now
I'm still learning to deal with Justin
wrong negativity of just some random guy
SiC in his apartment just talking about
a subject and people like literally hate
you for your opinion if I if I say I
don't use an Android phone and I'm
choosing to use an iPhone I'm the worst
person on earth to some people and so I
guess the class would mainly be about
how to how to deal with that how to deal
with someone not liking your content and
liking yourself first and liking what
you do primarily because once you love
what you do any like like that then
those comments don't don't mean anything
which means I'm still working on loving
absolutely loving what I do and so I can
block on all the negativity so even if
even in my level it it's a process and
how do you handle those haters do you
just you know I I used to do the whole
witty things I'm really good at shutting
people down but yes the reason I stopped
because I realized something in it I did
a flashback to when I was teaching and I
remember I had a fourth grade I had a
kid that was just you just bad he was
just he just acted out all the time and
I said keep giving him attention he's
just keep interrupting my class and I'll
be like so and so you need to do you
know you need to stop and then I've
realized once I just kept doing that the
good kids stopped getting my attention
so they turned bad so they can get my
attention it's it's it's it's an
interest in human psychology how that
works
they realized I'm to get my attention
they needed to act out so what I started
doing is I ignored him and I focus on
the people who are doing awesome Oh
Ginny you're doing so well over there
jack good job oh and then would it make
him do it's like oh crap I am I getting
attention anymore so he's first you sit
up and you like this and then I but I
all right good job John keep it up and
it worked every single time so I try to
applied it for youto I largely try to
ignore now because if they know they're
gonna get my attention their way they'll
they'll go out of their way to flatter
me even if even if they're lying at
least at least they're acting they're
pretending like they're acting good so
I'm I'm really learning it's the
psychology I'm not going to take a whole
course alright
the whole courses in psychology it's
crazy so yeah I Marge ignore me if they
get too malicious if it's like no racist
or anything which happens if it just
gets too out of hand I'll just block and
removing and forget about them but it
doesn't always I tried not to have it
comes in it
if I can interesting tell me how you how
you began your career on YouTube
oh my you know it's weird I it was a
2008 it was like January 2008 I bought
myself a camera a nice HD I spent about
1200 bucks I'm like yeah I'm gonna do
video so I can enhance my business the
camera set for 11 months in my cup in my
little cabinet I never used it and then
I went to a workshop from a well-known
youtuber Chris Pirillo and he was doing
a social media workshop and that's when
I started hearing more about this
YouTube thing and then a one day I was
watching in Ustream he's normally we at
2008 he was normally on Ustream
front page every day that was this thing
but I saw these two guys there on there
instead these two young guys and they
were just talking about their YouTube
channels and how they vlog and I'm like
what's flog what what is this thing that
they do and they were talking my name
was Sean clips so I I subscribed and
then I went back to the eastern mice
like hey guys guess what I subscribed
what does this mean I had no idea
they're like you'll get our videos I
want thrill watched like 20 of their
videos each and I just fell in love with
the format and I said I have to do this
and so I I end up trying it and slowly I
got you know I had to be friends with
them and it slowly just got a little bit
more popular I had no idea that I was
going to do this I was I was content
with my business this came out of
nowhere it was just an accident so what
were your early video videos like yes in
the Emily gesture cuz there
unfortunately had closed my account one
or two times and so those videos are
gone they were they were just like
everyday flaws it was just me sitting in
a chair like this talking to a camera
just like this and and just just talking
about random things that came up where
that was talking on a video game or
something I heard in the news or or
things that were happening in my life it
was it was very similar to how
I do now is just much more it wasn't as
professional or you know it wasn't
polished at all so you bill yourself as
the world's funniest tech reporter
absolutely yet yeah you're uh you're not
so focused on tech you're like talk
about pop culture I mean one of your
most one of your most popular videos was
you ripping at photos of Jason but you
kept you kept that Taylor Swift photo I
did I still have that magazine don't
tell anybody
yeah you know it's weird you know yeah
obviously I build myself a certain thing
but I don't like to typecast or restrict
myself into one thing just because you
know I do check I like to also talk
about entertainment entertainment news
too and they can I broaden my horizons
where I'm just not stuck in one genre
and I think that's it I don't want say
that some mistake yellow tech people
make but I think you know when you're
stuck in one place there's no room to
grow after a while and I want to you
know constantly be funny and available
to anybody who wants to watch me sorry
ya don't have Justin Bieber stuff in
here it's funny sometimes but I should
know what's to talk about how many more
it's all one direction now where you
been it's all one direction now yeah I
hope so
I hope to do it so I will I would be
sure that the next time if there's a one
direction I will thank you cuz that's
where I get my views you know they're
gonna die I'm there Harry Styles is his
officers we can't have that
his hair is too perfect he can't die yes
when you were starting your YouTube
video did you expect I had again I had
no perception I don't even know anything
about partner program I didn't know you
can make money off of it I just started
it just for the love of wanting to learn
how to be video so I hadn't know but
when I was when I found out that I can
take this seriously was the beginning of
2011 I was like you know that my
business was winding down my country
we're ending I was like do I want to try
to remove this or do I want to get into
this youtube thing and take it seriously
so I gave myself about eight months and
I said if I can make this work by the
end of 2011 then it's not meant to be
and by October 2011 I was comfortable
enough that I was making elsewhere I
could live on I said okay I beat my
whole schedule so that was really good
and then you made the move to Los
Angeles and now you're with your big
friend I am how do you how did you big
friend get together you know it was
weird cuz I was with another network
prior to that it didn't work out you
know it's a few months and it was it
just wasn't good relationship so I was
really negative against networks but
most of my friends were here in LA are
with big frame and there kept talking
enough house a family feel I was also an
I was friends with mr. guitar man who
you know is you know the husband of the
owner Sarah and so I asked him I said
dude what do you what's your opinion on
these news networks he he said he said I
think you should at least talk to my
wife and just see what you know what we
have to offer he said you know I think
you'll be happy talk to her and yeah we
worked some things out and I met her and
VidCon and we talked some more and I got
a really good feel that it wasn't just a
network trying to swoop me up and then
forget about me it was a network that
wanted to grow my audience which instead
of just getting my CPM you know give my
handsome so I was really happy about
that and I've been nothing but happy
with them they treated me so well
you know and it's been a blessing I
wouldn't be here without different in LA
at all oh yeah I mean whether it's
sponsored you know videos or you know
some brand deal of things or you know
actually big frames to want to help me
get introduced to Shira I did the
partner project where I was interviewed
with her and she liked the interview so
much as a hey why don't you do what's
training with me so it's like good
things have been going through them I'm
working on a deal with I can't say the
name of the magazine but it's a pretty
big magazine that wants me to do some
correspondent work with them really soon
so that's been through a big frame so
I'll try to expand out
of just sitting here doing the videos
everyday until you know doing some other
stuff often YouTube I'm really excited
about that do you have any a YouTube
personality to follow yes a follow stalk
would like what I mean I mean I can get
whatever you want to turn yeah no I used
to not say I have favorites but I really
are people ask so much that I finally
have to say but yeah wheezy waiter is my
number one favorite he's from Chicago
we were Freitas there you know so we
hung out sometimes Daily Grace who had
just chatted us yesterday is awesome
she's a she's our money for Friday
vlogger herself and just a constant she
puts out every day it's just crazy she's
just she's my think she's more insane
than I am and so yeah I think those two
really stand out you know when it comes
to news Phil DeFranco it's awesome you
know he he set the tone for you know how
to do news on YouTube so you know it's I
have a few favorites that I was you know
sent around there's a lot of other
people that you know I'm gonna you know
miss out on saying but those are my
premier people what are your feelings
about the YouTube community do you think
it's a close-knit community or is it
just you know back in Ohio time it was
closer but that's because YouTube was
smaller you know so it was you call it a
community I think now it's broken up
into several communities you know some
people might call them cliques but but
if that's just inevitable YouTube is
huge now so it doesn't have the same
closeness as before and no but I really
believe that you know I have a good
group of friends who support as seen
through that group of friends I get to
meet other people it's different here in
LA people are definitely into them
themselves in their own things I don't
think it's I don't think it's intention
on like malicious it's just everybody's
really busy so as much as I would love
for them to work with me I work with
them and promote you know I just have to
be patient and I haven't been patient
since I've been here I've been told by
people be patient some Russians I'm
slowing myself down and just trying to
pace it out a little bit have you ever
thought about doing like stand-up comedy
man I think I think stand-up is a
different beast is in the camera I am
highly edited you know jump cuts dunk I
think I can't do jump cut on stage I
know just I don't know I I do I do a lot
of shows on you know service call you
now and then on YouTube yeah and people
like those live shows I don't know it's
just stand up people are mean like the
audience is like it's like there there
should not like you if I've seen those
stand ups and I was like I don't know if
I want to do that I've been I've been
asked I've been asked if I want to do it
one day we'll never try it one day we'll
try and have failed miserably and curl
up in a ball and you might not hear from
me again yes I don't know I gotta build
my confidence not yet and I've been
invited like I've met the guy who runs
the Laugh Factory it's like yeah come on
down near your youtuber will let you in
free and you know they have some kind of
thing they do with Kevin Nealon where
you keep the meets with people and you
say yeah you talk to youtubers and so I
might go one one day just to check it
out
in your many years on YouTube what has
been the most innovative gadget out
there yeah I mean I I gotta say the
tablets kind of changed everything like
there was always smartphones going up
and you know the iPhone was out in
Android phones and I was a fan of all of
that but I think that the tablet just
surprised everybody because you know
when it first came out I laughed at it
it's like I was gonna use that I have a
laptop they helped don't even I need a
tablet for and and then I got one and
then it just the clouds parted and I
started to see oh this I see what this
device does it's an intermediary and it
really works I can sit at the couch and
use that so I think this is the year I
mean people were curious about them last
year but this is the year people are
really starting to get them because you
know Google came out with their own I
think you know
many came out and so the the tablet to
me has been the biggest innovation in
consumer tech so which tablet do you
have right now I have iPad Mini and I
had the iPad 2 what happened is I was a
wimp I think when I came I was like who
wants them yeah I was you know big so
who wants to many whatever that went
into Apple store and the Grove and I was
like I was going to look at it take a
picture and Instagram and laugh at it
look at this little thing so I put it in
my hand and take the picture and as soon
as I put it in my hand I was like it'll
just I just paused and then I look like
20 minutes later I was walking out with
one
I was like wait but I just spent six
what I don't like what I don't know what
happened but when I have to is like I
opened up the reading Apple said yes
this is the form factor this is the four
factor that works and I take it
everywhere now I didn't take my other
iPad because there's a little bit too
bulky I think I take it everywhere I
love it it's mine it's my child
so don't no don't harm it alright okay I
see you looking at it just keep it over
there yeah all right all right morning
you all right hey thanks for uh thanks
for stopping thanks for the interview
no problem thank you for coming here and
I've had a ball this is this is great
you're great thank you hey this is
Lamarr Wilson thank you for checking out
my interview at new media rockstars you
can visit me at youtube.com slash Lamarr
Wilson twitter.com slash Lamarr Wilson
it's Lamarr Wilson everywhere even
Google+ if you use it which you probably
don't but it just in case you do